la muerte de la jueza ruth báder
ginsburg no sólo ha dejado polémica por
la nominación de su sucesora también ha
rememorado un evento en casi las mismas
condiciones
el 13 de febrero de 2016 también año
electoral
murió el juez de la corte suprema-
antonine scalia en esa oportunidad del
presidente era un demócrata barack obama
y la vacante en la corte era de un
conservador constituyen la constitución
es bastante clara sobre lo que se supone
que debe suceder ahora cuando hay una
vacante en la corte suprema- el
presidente de eeuu debe nominar a
alguien más el por entonces precandidato
republicano a la presidencia donald
trump pedía que se dilatara el proceso
para elegir a un nuevo juez
que creo que depende de mitch mcconnell
y de todos los demás detenerlo se llama
demora demora demora un pedido que fue
secundado por los senadores de su
partido en cabeza de mitch mcconnell
quien también ha dado un giro de 180
grados a su discurso en este 2020
dejemos que el pueblo estadounidense
decida el senador revisar apropiadamente
el asunto cuando considere la
calificación del nominado el próximo
presidente no minará a quien sea
ya estamos escuchando afirmaciones
incorrectas de que no hay tiempo
suficiente para examinar y confirmar a
un nominado podemos desacreditar este
mito en unos 30 segundos a partir de hoy
quedan 43 días hasta el 3 de noviembre y
104 días hasta el final de este congreso
sin embargo los republicanos no son los
únicos que han cambiado su postura el
entonces presidente obama hizo caso
omiso y nominó al presidente de la corte
de apelaciones de washington
merrick garland pero los senadores
republicanos se negaron siquiera a dar
una audiencia y carla no pudo llegar a
la corte suprema trump ganó en las
elecciones de noviembre y nominó al
conservador millward shock que hoy es
uno de los nueve jueces de la corte